c'est une petite boutique au ses troupes
de trouville voilà vingt ans maintenant
que la chiffo s'inscrit en toutes
lettres dans le tissu social canet cette
structure emploie jusqu'à cinquante et
une personnes en contrat à durée
déterminée d'insertion
encadrés par six salariés permanents
vous êtes au coeur de l'atelier
d'insertion socioprofessionnelle
c'est pour ça que je voulais que ce
matin vous le regardiez qu'on revoie un
petit peu les petites choses or tu vois
il ya christine cécile benoît nathalie
clair ou bien encore martin un jour par
semaine
l'équipe d'encadrants de la chiffo se
réunit autour de la table afin comme on
dit de faire tourner la boutique
puis c'est indispensable pour toute
l'équipe il faut qu on échange sur les
actions qui sont mises en place et à la
chiffo sur ce qui se fait à l'extérieur
sur les salariés
on est tous à des degrés différents
d'intervention et du coup si la passe
temps collectif les salariés sont pas
accompagnés dans leur globalité
donc c'est important que tout s'articule
et pour la ville d'esch faut aussi ce
quotidien justement il s'articule
essentiellement autour du vêtement
solidaire ici les salariés sont pour la
plupart des personnes en difficulté des
sans emploi de longue durée
il ya 73 % de femmes mais aussi des
hommes
toutes et tous ont dû réussir leur
examen de passage avant d'intégrer
l'atelier on recrute des personnes sur
leurs projets et non sur leurs
difficultés sociales taz insiste
beaucoup mais très vite on oublie que ce
sont des cabossés parce que la magie
chiffo c'est qu'en fait le salarié dès
l'instant où il a signé son contrat de
travail et wii prend ses fonctions ici
sous huit ou quinze jours vous voyez
plus des difficultés
vous voyez un professionnel qui très
rapidement rentrer dans son rôle et qui
tous les jours on apprend ici on
travaille particulièrement la vente mais
on travaille aussi des compétences comme
pressing blanchisserie et logistique
toutes ces compétences là ils vont être
transférés vers le métier qu'ils
souhaitent exercer et ses charges à nous
de les mettre en avant et en valeur de
valoriser leur parcours pour qu'ils
reprennent confiance et qu'ils élevaient
qu'ils aillent vers l'extérieur et vers
les autres entreprises rémunérés au smic
horaire
ces salariés en contrat à durée
déterminée d'insertion sont accompagnés
pour une durée maximale de 24 mois
financé à hauteur de 70 % par des
subventions
cette structure est soumise à une
obligation de résultat
rapprocher le chantier d'insertion du
monde du travail ordinaire depuis deux
trois ans on est à 60 % de sorties nous
qu'on appelle dynamique ça veut dire que
nous salariés soit accède à la formation
qualifiante soit trouver un emploi
donc on atteint nos objectifs et puis
pour tous ceux pour lesquels ce n'est
pas encore fini cécile s'arrange
vraiment en fin de parcours pour qu'il
ya un relais avec l'accompagnateur pôle
emploi et qui est des dispositifs de
poursuite de parcours qui s'enclenche ya
aucune personne qui part de la chiffo et
qui se retrouvent à retourner à pôle
emploi avec un rien dans l'humain voilà
plus de quatre mois maintenant qu'annick
a rejoint la chiffo demain nous irons à
sa rencontre
à l'heure de l'embauché